JOHN ROBERTS REPORTING FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THANKS.
IF WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS
WITH THE PANEL.
IT APPEARS NATIONWIDE RAIDS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO HAVE
ALREADY BEEN ORDERED TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY ARE BACK ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP POSTPONED THE
ACTION ONCE.
NOW THE CONTROVERSIAL EXPERT TO
OPERATION IS SCHEDULED TO START
ON SUNDAY.
CORRESPONDENT JILL INTERNAL
GILLIAN TURNER HAS MARGINALLY
BURIED >> THOUSANDS OF
UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS ACROSS THE
U.S. ARE BRACING FOR WHAT COULD
BE A TRAUMATIC WEEKEND AHEAD.
SOURCES TELL FOX NEWS
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT PLANS TO DETAIN AND
DEPORT UP TO 2,000 INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES WHO ALREADY HAVE
DEPORTATION ORDERS ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING IN 1 OF 10 TARGETED
CITIES.
BURIED ICE OFFICIALS
AREN'T DENYING THE REPORT OR
OFFERING SPECIFICS OF THE PLAN,
BUT TELL FOX NEWS ICE
PRIORITIZES THE ARREST AND
REMOVAL OF UNLAWFULLY PRESENT
ALIENS WHO POSE A THREAT TO
NATIONAL SECURITY, PUBLIC SAFETY
AND BORDER SECURITY.
AS NEWS OF THE POTENTIAL RATES
SPREAD ACROSS WASHINGTON TODAY,
DEMOCRATIC LAWMAKERS RESPONDED
WITH ALARM.
>> THIS BRUTAL ACTION WILL
TERRORIZE CHILDREN AND TEAR
FAMILIES APART.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN DAYS,
THE SO-CALLED PROGRESSIVE SQUAD
BANDED TOGETHER WITH PARTY
ELDERS.
>> I'M EXTREMELY CONCERNED.
MY DISTRICT IS 50% IMMIGRANT.
>> SOME EVEN OFFERING LEGAL
DEVICE VIA TWITTER BY MIGRANTS
WHO FEAR GETTING STOPPED OR
QUESTIONED BY ICE OVER THE NEXT
FEW DAYS.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP INSISTS
LARGE-SCALE DEPORTATIONS ARE AN
IDEAL SOLUTION TO WHAT HE CALLS
AMERICA'S INTEGRATION CRISIS.
>> I DON'T CALL THEM RATES.
I SAY THEY CAME IN ILLEGALLY AND
WE ARE BRINGING THEM OUT LEGALL
LEGALLY.
>> APPREHENSIONS OF MIGRANTS
ALONG THE SOUTHERN BORDER
PLUNGED A WHOPPING 28% OVER THE
PAST MONTH TO ABOUT 104,000
PEOPLE IN JUNE.
A STATISTIC THAT'S GOT
IMMIGRATION EXPERTS QUESTIONING
WHY RATES ARE NEEDED.
NOW THERE'S NO CONCERN TONIGHT
ON CAPITOL HILL ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF COLLATERAL
DEPORTATION.
THE SITUATION IN WHICH MIGRANTS
WHO AREN'T CURRENTLY ICE TARGETS
GET SWEPT UP DURING THE ARREST